hello everyone and welcome to the
mindscape podcast i'm your host sean
carroll
n equals one that's fighting words in
scientific circles where n means the
number of data points you have and one
is the smallest number of data points
you can have that is more than zero when
you're looking for trends or features of
scientific systems and you only have one
data point it's tempting to say things
of sweeping generality but it's very
hard to know that you're on the right
track sadly there's a famous case where
we're stuck in some sense with n equals
one which is the origin of life here on
earth not only do we only have one
example of life in the universe namely
life here on earth but as far as we know
life only began once or if it began
multiple times the evidence has been
wiped out of everything else so what can
we do about this if we want to
understand things like what is the
likelihood of life elsewhere and if it
is out there how do we go looking for it
so today's guest batul kachar is an
astrobiologist and synthetic biologist
who studies paleogenomics so i think
that's how you pronounce it i never know
how many syllables are in these biology
words but the idea is to learn about
early life not just by looking at
fossils because many fossils that we
would like to have just don't exist or
all the interesting information has been
wiped out but to look at current life to
compare the genomes and the proteins and
other things going on in different
contemporary organisms and learn about
their commonalities look in detail at
their family trees right that's the
philo in phylogenomics and try to
reconstruct what it was like in the past
what are the structures that we all
share and the great news is that this
kind of approach moves us from n equals
one to n equals quite a few because
after all there are a lot of organisms
on earth today and there were a lot of
evolutionary events that they went
through so amazingly
the folks in this field are able to push
our knowledge back more than three
billion years to think about our last
universal common ancestor maybe even
about the origin of life itself and you
learn a lot of things along the way as
you'll hear in the podcast for example
one obvious moral of the story is that
there's a relationship between
biological transitions and physical
transitions you know here on earth we
have geology we have chemistry we have
atmospheric science there's even
astrophysics with changes in the sun the
temperature of the atmosphere and there
are biological changes in what biology
can do and even though the total mass of
stuff in biology is much less than the
total mass of the earth it still has an
outsized role in what happens uh in both
geology and atmospheric science so
you're gonna learn a lot about biology i
learned a lot since i know almost
nothing about it and the fascinating
complex history of how things have been
going since life began to now
with important implications for what we
should be looking at for life elsewhere
so let's go
[Music]
welcome to the mindscape podcast hi
thanks for having me so it's interesting
to think about a comparison between what
you do for a living and what uh some of
my friends do for a living the
observational astronomers you know they
look out into the sky and they look at
things that are very far away and
because of a
finite speed of light
the things they're looking at they're
seeing from the past right so we get
automatic access to the past just
because the speed of light is slow in
cosmology now
you're looking at the past but it's much
more complicated for you because you're
trying to figure out what was going on
with life
and as far as i can tell you're mostly
looking at
things that are currently alive and
trying to infer the past is that more or
less accurate
it is it is fairly accurate
i
sherlock holmes of the past
uh if i may say so myself that we are
trying to understand the
what happened billions of years ago
by relying on very limited um and mostly
raised uh information that exists today
and so um we want to go into the details
a little bit you know i always tell
people that the mindscape audience are
not experts they're they're not
biologists or physicists or whatever but
they're willing to get into the details
a little bit so um
what do we do like what do we actually
look at i guess maybe the first thing to
try to do is to say what are we trying
to figure out are you mostly interested
in what like the dna the genome was of
the early organisms or is it more to it
than that
it is uh i'm broadly speaking i am
interested in the way they express
themselves their behavior
and how did they lay um they provide the
foundation of life we see around us
today if you think about it um so life
is a minimum
or approx approximately let's say 3.5
billion year old
and every minute and second and day that
we
spent on this planet today we rely on
the innovations that life figured out
over this time i think this is
incredibly profound yet we know very
little about these past steps that uh
most likely enabled what we see around
us today so i am trying to understand
the first steps
and is it is it a matter of you know
looking at very different organisms and
comparing their genomes and seeing what
probably stuck around for a long time
yeah so there are different ways
to do this although not not a lot of
different ways
so we can either read the rock record
which is a prime way of inferring the
past and try to understand from the
remnants of past organisms
what sort of story they tell us to
understand the environment that they
lived in or what sort of maybe
catastrophes they had to
bear through
alternatively we could use the dna that
exists today and make inferences
firstly to understand the relationship
between today's organisms which we do
fairly well the genomic um
sequence right now is more resolved than
ever before right this is not to say
that we have a complete picture in hand
but it's probably better than it has
ever been and we try to um infer the
relationships between the organisms
anyway but a sort of a on top of that a
relatively new application
of this is to read these
phylogenetic trees the tree view of life
to infer the ancestral states of these
organisms and if you want to drill a
little deeper to understand the
relationship between these organisms
and their ancestors at the molecular
level so that's what i'm trying to do
and uh actually tell me a little bit
more about the rocks or the fossils
because you know i know if we look at
dinosaurs we care about fossils but are
there really fossils that are telling us
uh that are capturing an organism from
three billion years ago
so this is why it's challenging and why
also i think it's incredibly exciting we
have very little information we maybe
have the tops handful of rocks that um
relatively uh
harvard i'm sorry we have a few rocks
that have relatively well conserved uh
fossil information
um because we are dealing with really
really really
uh early in life right we're looking at
the
uh at life that existed say
over three billion years into the past
so so what do you do with that you try
to look at the morphology or some sort
of certain chemistry maybe that you will
be able to extract from these rocks that
will tell you something about the
organism that may have been the
responsible party that left the
signature on the rock so um
we we have really a handful of these
things to make sense of so it is fair to
say that when it comes to understanding
the past we make a lot of assumptions
the picture is far from complete and
you're trying to connect the dots using
a few data points
and then and then try to write a story
about what um what
early life looked like
but just to be
very very clear those little rocks those
little fossils you're not getting dna
from them are you no so these are way
too old to extract from maybe if you
deal with a permafrost or some conserved
organism in some
you know ice location you may be able to
uh extract a dna for maybe a few
thousand uh ten thousand a year old or
something but when it comes to billion
years old uh you you don't have much
actually you have nothing
okay so then let's go back to then the
phylogenetic trees these seem to be more
the way to get at the dna so um
we get dna from a whole bunch of
organisms i don't know i mean how many
organisms do we understand the complete
genome for
so uh
we don't quite know right it's very
difficult to understand what we don't
understand or that to know that we are
not understanding what we are thinking
we are understanding so
the more we explore the oceans the more
we explore all this you know maybe
previously difficult to access locations
the more we are finding amazing the
microbial diversity today
that's good for uh people in my field
because we rely on today's diversity to
infer the past so the more data we
gather from today's diver biodiversity
the better it is for us or the easier it
is for us to understand um the past that
doesn't mean it's easy
but it makes our job a little easier so
it totally depends on what you are
trying to access what question that
you're interested in what system you
want to explore
and and how well refined and understood
that system is today yeah but forgetting
about like the fraction i know there's
we keep discovering more and more
organisms which is i mean good for you
right full employment you're never going
to run out of things to do
but uh
when we study these i'm i'm very much uh
uh ignorant about this so do you just
do we collectively just discover a new
microbe and then sequence its dna and
put it in a database somewhere
yeah so uh that's exactly um what what
uh we do and by we i don't mean me
exactly that's what uh they used to do
very well uh and find the you know the
more
organisms are discovered or or their
sequence the more we develop these
technologies that enable us to sequence
them properly uh the more database we
have in terms of understanding today's
biodiversity but my approach is similar
to perhaps a linguist that is trying to
resurrect an ancient language it's it's
very similar if you were to um you know
reconstruct the ancestor of
the modern egyptian what would you do
right you would try to understand
whatever
ancient civilizations left on in a
similar way maybe in some cases on the
rocks you know like what did they write
behind what is the written record that
that they left behind and you also would
independently but also complement in a
complementary fashion would try to
understand the culture of these old
civilizations and try to understand what
sort of i don't know cups that they use
where did they live did they have
windows okay what does that mean that
they constantly protected themselves
from the sun okay they were living in a
hot environment so it's very similar to
to what we do in a way that we are
trying to extract the ancient language
of today's biology um and there are a
lot of gaps perhaps similar to in
linguist that is trying to extract a
really old language that there will be
gaps or maybe mistranslated stories uh
but we gotta start from somewhere yeah
so is it as simple as you look at all
sorts of different microbes or even you
know more complex organisms and you say
what are the common
sequences of dna and those probably are
old is that basically the idea
so that's where we start we we first
take a picture of the entire story and
try to understand what does the ancestry
tells us about my lab we've developed
this system where we took this a little
a step further
and used synthetic biology and created
these ancient dna sequences in the lab
so if the listeners are thinking ding
ding ding jurassic park
calm down it's not that bad
it's much older and it's actually the
opposite of jurassic park anyway but uh
so we we are trying to um we actually
developed this system where we aimed to
engineer modern organisms uh by um
by basically treating them like like a
shuttle in a way and by directly
modifying their genome with these
ancient dna sequences so we um wanted to
animate uh
the ancient life components in the lab
so that's sort of where the fun started
for me because looking at the tree or
the relationship is really like looking
at a picture it tells you only so much
it's more static i wanted to
bring them back to life and and see what
they do and and what they um impose on
the organism
ultimately to compare that behavior with
what we extract from the rock record
right and but well i guess i'm still
missing something pretty simple here how
do we know what sequences of dna are
ancient and how do we know which ones
are recent
okay that's a very good question so we
rely on a lot of mathematical models a
lot of evolutionary algorithms uh to
make these predictions and it is safe to
say that we are making a lot of
predictions and a lot of assumptions so
it is we need to sort of limit our own
limitations and our own statistical
significances or lack thereof sometimes
um and know to a degree how confident we
are that we are dealing with a true
ancestor so if it is
we are we have 60 certainties and then
we have 60 certainty and um and well
because of using these evolutionary
algorithms we have some idea about for
example when two organisms that live
today when did their ancestors survive
on this planet so was it a billion year
ago was it two billion years ago um if
you track everything we are all
connected that's the major in a way the
most poetic and beautiful assumptions of
biology that the entire
biological taxa is connected through
ancestry right so if you go further and
further you go back to the last
universal common ancestor and that's
going to take you to 3.5 billion year
old so you need to then ask yourself
what do i think that existed back then
did life function exactly the same as we
see today or were there components that
were even more older than the rest and
if i were to assume that at last
universal common ancestor existed with
components similar to what i see today
what were those
and so if i look in the dna of a
bacterium or a fungus uh can i literally
identify sequences of base pairs that
also appear in human dna or uh
palm tree dna
yeah of course there are there are
segments that in in all um in all modern
life today uh that that is shared right
so there are components that are shared
we all rely on translation machinery for
example it is almost imagining that we
all have the same
computational processor inside of us you
do i do a plant does we all rely on the
same system
life needs to translate the language of
dna into
hopefully meaningful sometimes
meaningless protein sequences and then
use them for whatever um
there's required so if you abstract life
if you abstract the complexity that you
see today
like it or not you are reaching to some
components that are shared so you may
assume that whatever is shared across
all life today may be the common
component uh and was the common uh
component or shared component in the
past as well and maybe this is just
worth uh rehearsing because i'm sure
that most of our listeners have heard
this in high school biology or whatever
but this machinery that you're talking
about is what takes the genetic info
from dna converts it to rna and then to
proteins you're saying that that basic
set up is common to literally all the
life we've seen ever on earth yes i i
would say universal but because we
didn't
find life outside of earth i will just
say teren but so so far all life we know
uh relies on this machinery and maybe um
a human system would be a little bit
more complex of course than archaea in
archaea may be more complex than
bacteria
but in some form the same the
computational system
so to speak exists in all life
um it's it's quite remarkable you may
imagine that some computer from
60s
and then you can look at the computers
today and you may find similar
components in each even though they look
absolutely different
maybe they look bigger and smaller
by the way bigger computer doesn't mean
more complex right like a very small i
watch is actually arguably more
complicated than a giant processor
you know from 60s 70s
um i keep saying 6670s i don't know the
computer's background to be honest i
wasn't alive
yeah
i've seen photos so it's the um it's
very similar in biology in a very
simplified way if i may put it that way
and is there again a naive question um
is there anything that we can learn from
studying protein the protein side of
this story in its own right or are the
proteins basically determined by the dna
so we can just study the dna
so we we use both information to access
early life components we use dna and we
also use their products proteins so we
in general in if we can track the past
using both
information source sources but um
hopefully they will agree with each
other whatever we infer and if they
don't we report that as well so it is um
but we we try to rely on anything we can
it's the if
you know
we will do what we can whatever we have
around us we will try to extract the
juice out of it and try to understand
the past life in any way we can
and what about the again my ignorance
showing um there's
dna that codes for proteins and there's
non-coding dna right junk dna like is
that is the junk dna also useful to you
in these investigations
um i know there's a lot of um
debate on the way when we call these
components junk because we don't quite
know
yes truly what what they do but uh
because i work with microbial systems in
general we don't deal with a lot of
nonsensical so to speak or mysterious
dna that's also makes my life a bit more
complicated given i gotta limit my
amount of um
you know the in a way the battles
that i have
battles yes so i i rely on the the
components that we know for sure are
essential for life okay and then we try
to extract the past
um using those
what's the secret to your best night's
sleep first toss out the memory foam
upgrade to awara organic luxury hybrid
mattress with natural foam and new
zealand wool fiber awara features
premium sri lankan latex and wrapped
coil springs to provide contour and a
touch of bounds for supported sleep
throughout the night and the organic new
zealand wool keeps you cozy and cool
i've tried aware and honestly i was
skeptical at first but i'll tell you
it's the best night's sleep i've ever
had and every time you choose awara know
that 10 trees will be planted to restore
forests in kenya uganda and tanzania for
a limited time you'll get 499 dollars in
free accessories two natural latex
pillows cotton sheets and a waterproof
mattress protector with every mattress
purchase and feel good knowing awara
plants 10 trees with every purchase so
sleep better knowing you just planted a
small forest to redeem go to
www.awarasleep.com
a-w-a-r-a-s-l-e-e-p
dot com discount applied at checkout
and so i think you mentioned you gave
away the fact that uh using techniques
like this we trace
luca the last universal common ancestor
to about 3.5 billion years ago but
that's not the origin of life right i
mean can how how far away is it from the
origin of life is that even something we
can say
it's it's not easy to
uh put a you know very clear mark in
terms of the timeline and and say this
is when
the threshold from chemistry to biology
happened we don't quite know
but uh we we have some reason to think
that
around 4.1 billion years into the past
something happened so it's we're looking
400 million years following planet
formation
and um it's it's very quick if you think
about it um it's quite magnificent that
that's sort of the time that set the
stage uh in terms of the planetary
context that enabled um the the
chemistry crossing this threshold to
biology a participant some sort of
agency
something with an agency that that's
enabled everything we see today
and it's not probably directly related
to
uh your research in paleogenetics but
um
i ask everyone every early life origin
of life biologist who comes on the show
uh do you think life began more than
once uh and do you think that
starting life out is pretty easy and
pretty robust or did it require some
really really unlikely fluctuations and
we just got lucky
well that's that's a very interesting
question we actually do some work um
in in the one level we rely on today's
biology and rewind the tape and try to
understand the ancient systems
and and track them as far as we can in
terms and we need biology for that given
that we are tracking life but at the
same time we are trying to start from
chemicals and then see experimentally
whether we can generate some behaviors
uh in or some organizational attributes
that may look like life so we are trying
to access that time point in using both
ants uh from uh backwards from today and
forward from past and um
so to answer your question if it was
very easy we would probably have done it
by now in ourselves in the lab right so
um either nature is a better chemist
than us that is for sure it's not a
competition
but uh and but i also think that within
our lifetimes it's very likely that we
will be solving this particular problem
of life's origin now we'll we'll be able
to replicate exactly what happens into
the past no one can no nobody has a time
machine i mean i'm looking at you i
don't have one
um but it's the we don't so we will
probably never know if what we created
alone is exactly what happened but we
will start constraining
uh what we generate the moment we get
there and i really think that within our
lifetime that's possible
so it does um
i i'm totally on board most everyone i
ask that question to gives that kind of
answer like we don't know
it must be pretty hard to start life but
we really don't know but let's be more
specific about it you mentioned this
whole
mechanism by which dna becomes rna and
then there's the ribosome which converts
that rna into proteins
and that's common to all life but it
seems awfully complex
like how what are the thoughts that we
have about how undirected chemistry
could have come up with some something
quite so structured and intricate
i think there are there are laboratories
right now that are trying to piece
together this information from different
ends
um we we can create systems that are
able to process some level of
information
albeit limited or however much you know
we directed and we feed that information
we see that happening however we can't
make the system evolvable yet which we
needed we need that component for to put
pinadas life
and um but
yeah
so
so we can do that so we can get
self-replicating molecules but like a
separate idea of a machine the ribosome
right i mean there's something more i
think grandeur that is um bigger than
translation machinery or a common shared
component i think maybe there are
i don't want to divide these problems
into different disciplines because i
nature does not know it yet right like
okay yeah
who said we divide things physics
biology chemistry but nature does not
know that right so
um
you know so i'm not sure um you know how
likely this is but everything that that
we study
may be um founded by some
you know grandeer chemical information
system that we are yet to find out
and you know we we
we may be slicing the pie way too much
here because
whether life chooses a translation
missionary is a universal system and
then runs with it that's that's one
problem and we don't know why life does
that either you can say okay life is
lazy and it is lazy you know we see this
more you know over and over again you
see this fan uh organisms chill
different isotopes in the atmosphere
they always pick the lighter one because
they just don't want to deal with the
heavy one right so physics imposes
itself a lot right in the way biology
operates itself but there may be
we don't know exactly what enables life
as a chemical system
for it to in
to explore solutions what enables life
as a chemical system that evolves and
and figures out solutions to the
problems and then maintains a memory of
these problems over billions of years of
time we don't know what enables
lives in
life to do that that's i think the sort
of the
bigger grander problem here that we have
yet to solve
okay maybe um
the origin of life is of course
fascinating for philosophical as well as
scientific reasons but
i mostly want to talk about things that
you and your collaborators are actually
able to learn about not the hard
problems that you know everyone would
like to learn about so
i get the impression from reading your
papers etc that the great oxygenation
event is something that we you can
actually say something about uh using
your technique so maybe tell the
audience what that event is and what
we're able to learn about it
okay so that's actually very very good
point because you now took us from 3.5
billion years into the past you know we
are traveling forward in time and uh and
to almost been a billionaire and and
what we see is the
significant change in the atmosphere in
terms of the levels of oxygen and it's
not quite i think cert there's a lot of
debate as to why this may have happened
coming from there's a lot of geo
geological reasons there's a biological
reasons and maybe it depends on whom you
ask and what they know they will tell
you different um
maybe they will point to the different
directions as the major drivers of this
rise of oxygen that being said um
in in our system we were able to see the
signatures of this atmospheric change
embedded on the proteins themselves i
still remember the day we
just sort of found this i i
got chills because you know you would
think that proteins are just sort of
this
i don't know i love protein so i always
think oh they are not getting the the
respect that they deserve
in the end most of the time people ask
me hey
are you saying that the change in the
protein enabled it triggered a big
change in the atmosphere how because how
is that possible because we're looking
at layers and layers of hierarchical
steps in between how would such a
molecule
can make such an impact and i tell them
with all due respect i mean if you
remove i don't know lizards today
with all the respect of lizards
you would probably not feel this much
but if you remove like molybdenum we are
all doomed okay we're doomed like we
won't last period so so we do rely on
these elements and molecules and
proteins to enable everything and that
is to me one of the main reasons why we
should study proteins but also their
evolution
in deep time so coming back to the rise
of oxygen we were able to see one of the
prime drivers of this metabolism today
we were able to access its ancestry
access and resurrected as three billion
year old ancestors engineer them inside
microbes and then find out how the
microbe responds to its own past and
choose oxygen and carbon dioxide
differently
and we were able to see that some parts
of the protein
responsible from
greeting oxygen today were in fact
different
um 2.5 billions of years ago so
it's almost like oxygen tickles this
protein and we can see these signatures
on it it's just so amazing
that is pretty amazing but you know as
you mentioned i did skip a billion years
so maybe uh
give us some context for what the world
was like 2.5 billion years ago so before
this great oxygenation event uh did did
we have
uh eukaryotes did we have cells with
nuclei did we have multicellular life at
that time what was the world like
so we didn't have eukaryotes okay it was
uh it was pretty
um in a way maybe boring it was not it
was a pretty solid life if you were a
microbe
so so the rise of oxygen is a very you
know it's a horrible catastrophe for for
microbes but it's great news if you are
eukaryote or multicellular organism
because the the sage the stage is being
set for eukaryotes to rise but they
don't show up for another few million
years 400 million years after the rise
of oxygen they do so
although again there are um there are
microbes and there's no oxygen so that's
very important because when we also look
for life elsewhere we
look for oxygen as a sort of or we think
oxygen will be a smoking gum but no the
um first you know over billion year of
life didn't have any oxygen and microbes
were just fine they were just hanging
out they weren't probably as big
in terms of size uh but you're looking
into as far as we know a really hot
planet uh probably acidic
um and uh but a relatively stable
atmosphere because that happened fairly
fast uh on this planet um and and and
microbial diversity
as far as we can tell but eukaryotes are
all the complicated and maybe more
exciting for some organisms didn't show
up for another billion years okay so we
have uh microbial life the atmosphere is
mostly nitrogen and carbon dioxide i
guess
exactly and there's of course very rich
sulfur chemistry going on and we we have
different levels of metals in the oceans
um compared to following the rise of
oxygen that we definitely see a shift in
different elemental abundances
uh over time
and the uh microbes are they mostly in
the ocean or are they on land or do we
even get to say that
i i am probably
not quite sure about that actually i
probably shouldn't say either way but
but because we are able to infer the
ancient oceans well most of the things
we infer about them also comes from that
locality
okay so the
oxygenation event
i think you already said this but it it
skipped by me do we think that it was
chemistry first and then the biology
made use of it or did biology actually
cause the oxygenation
so it's it depends in fact there were
just recent papers that said it was
primarily geological uh
trigger but for a biologist of course
the invention of photosynthesis and the
sort of cyanobacterial the origination
of cyanobacteria
the emergence of cyanobacteria rather
all triggered the rise of oxygen
and what we see of course we have the
invention of we
organisms microbes were able to do
unoxygenic photosynthesis back then but
the oxygenating photosynthesis of course
didn't take place until the rise of
oxygen now you may argue that
life invented uh
oxidative photosynthesis in response to
the oxygen uh but then how did you know
the environment affect the organisms and
and vice versa it's quite a big uh
unknown because again nobody had a
clipboard and when it comes to the past
um we make a lot of assumptions
so you know so just to restate it so i
understand so it's possible that there
was just geology that spewed some oxygen
into the atmosphere and if that's true
then the existing microbes were not
adapted to that and they had to quickly
adapt uh but it's also possible that
some clever microbes learned how to do
photosynthesis and started creating
oxygen and it's their fault
yeah so cyanobacteria can do both of
these things it can do an aerobic
photosynthesis in
aerobic but you know early organism
lifestyle i guess there was a lot of
stromadelites right and there's uh
there's definitely more than oxygen than
the rise of oxygen on this planet
methanogens are quite a you know sort of
a they were running the show
um and a lot of
ammonia and ammonia oxidizing later on
these bacteria showed up so so it is uh
definitely just it is definitely more
than oxygen okay when it comes to the
rise of oxygen but we know that the
photosynthesis definitely played a
significant role in the composition of
the atmosphere
okay that's fair and in particular i
keep reading about rubisco
in your in your research so that's a
protein right that's a protein that does
something important
that's a relatively large protein uh
it's one of the highest expressed the
most abundant proteins that exist today
and but one of the big questions of
course is that we know that for the this
behavior of this protein impacts the
biomass that is available today yet we
really know
almost
nothing about when it comes to the
ancient planet's biomass
so so this is why again understanding we
go back to sort of understanding the
contemporary organisms and their
behavior and or and the proteins in
which you know that they enable what we
see that they do anyway and so
understanding the um ancestral versions
or of these proteins makes it you know
with more exciting the ability to
perhaps one day calculate the biomass of
early earth but rubisco uh rubisco is
involved in carbon fixation it's quite a
um
important enzyme that
that functions in the production of the
biomass
at the same time it's a pretty slow
catalyst
considering the important job it does so
a lot of
synthetic biology applications has been
towards improving the function of
rubisco um in in one way or another so
we we wanted to know uh where the hell
did rubisco come from and um and and how
did it behave billions of years ago
because
one thing that makes rubisco exciting
from a geology point of view is that
when we look at even stromatolites and
maybe look at this early life we have a
way of knowing that life extends itself
all the way to 3.5 billion years old
like when we say this is how old life is
how do we know that we know that because
this remnants of these bugs that once
lived in these environments tell us that
hey i did something that is similar to
what an organism that around you today
does
and that is that i chewed the amount of
carbon dioxide in the atmosphere though
the isotopes in the atmosphere
similarly that a micro in your in the
future in your time today does
uh so uh so so we basically compare that
past information to today's data set and
and see if what we find is biological or
if it is abiotic uh so of course
discerning uh the the two records is
just so hard right it's it's tricky
just very fun i highly recommend
attending geology meetings about these
timings very just uh really heated
conversations i love it so it's the uh
and
when it comes so when i i remember when
i first
saw this i was actually at harvard at
that time and indiana
drew the sort of timeline on the board
and said okay this is how old life is in
this there is a carbon record a
biological carbon record that dates all
the way to 3.5 billion in the past and i
thought okay wait wait wait
what's the protein that did that right
so there must be when you talk about
metabolism and early life all i hear is
molecules what is the molecule that
cause this
and and then comes rubisco so it blew my
mind i thought okay wait a second so are
you telling me that a protein that
exists today existed three point
something billion years ago and we are
able to read its
record we are able to read its signature
and we are assuming it is similar to
what we see around us today
whoa
especially when we know
that atmosphere it wasn't the same right
we know the significant changes as you
said right nitrogen amount or oxygen you
know the different chemistries
how is that possible
so um and then i realized we don't know
it it's again it's an assumption we sort
of
assume that because we don't quite know
because we think we can't right so how
can we access
billion-year-old evolution of an enzyme
uh so that's where we came in and that's
that's where uh you know that's the
uh what i will be doing actually is a
part of this new nasa center uh that we
will be investigating these problems i'm
so excited
it's good we could tell um so this is
actually and it's especially good you
don't even know how good it is because i
just recently did a podcast with nigel
goldenfeld who is a physicist who works
on life also
uh and we mentioned we were both fans of
michael russell's work on the origin of
life and the quote that i always use
from michael is that the purpose of life
is to hydrogenate carbon dioxide
and so what you're telling me is that
when you hear a statement like that
you're like that's all molecules what's
the protein that does it and the answer
is rubisco orbisco is the protein
responsible for hydrogenating carbon
dioxide
the it is one of many there are many
enzymes but uh
i guess what what i was trying to
highlight is that we
we know very little right about about
the past so we try to understand the
significant
um uh players of
our time now and then pin these
essential roles on their ancestry as
well which makes total sense that's
that's you know we have to start from
somewhere um but i mean of course you
know we are it's not to say that a
molecule alone can can do what life it's
it's an entire system that is
interacting with itself and and that's
that's the heart uh problem right it's
similar um
life detection in a way it's similar to
trying to understand ancient life you
you are
trying to
translate what molecules are enabling
that planet to do uh and and as i said
there are a lot of different steps in
between uh so this is not necessarily to
say that okay molecules and that's it
you know but it's it's there are a lot
of uh
complex interactions involved in this
and we need to of course tie them in
together uh but you know we also need to
uh understand each of them in the most
deep way we
possibly can so the the problem we
picked were the the ancestry of the
molecules themselves and is
is this what you were actually able to
do i mean with rubisco you're saying
that it's all around here today it's in
us today we still use it that particular
you're saying enzyme and protein but
enzymes are in this sense a kind of
protein right a kind of protein that
helps yeah they are we can just say that
there are proteins that can have a
catalytic activity they can do right you
know cool and fast kinetics in general
but
but the enzymes are proteins so we can
just call them proteins with large okay
um so yeah to today's life of course not
us but microbes use
um rubisco uh and plants of course and
uh but we
uh
as
by i mean living organisms uh rely on in
on such
metabolisms so this is not to say that
this is one most important enzyme out
there but that's one of the
main
or thought to be one of the main
enzymes moving forward so our approach
has been
using the dna sequences today
sort of predict this ancient version
just like as i was saying early on like
a linguist
and then
reconstruct this ancient dna sequence
use synthetic biology and actually
synthesize them in the lab that's that's
when we
say resurrection so now we made them
didn't just reconstruct them and then
engineer them inside organisms by
swapping what is currently in the
organism with this ancestral version
and then watch what the organism will do
in response to this ancient component if
in fact
this protein is the prime dominator of
this metabolism uh will it also
impose itself in a way that it
replicates uh or maybe contradicts what
we see in the rock record so we were
able to
engineer the billion-year-old version we
are now working on the older variants so
we want to go uh
further away from the go grade oxidation
event and access the variance that we
think existed
when there was no oxygen on this planet
what makes rubisco interesting is that
it's an old enzyme it is slow it's also
very confused it cannot differentiate
oxygen from carbon dioxide very well
and that was really the main start point
here that um we are trying to increase
the specificity of this enzyme towards
carbon dioxide and perhaps maybe we are
not better engineers or chemists than
nature we cannot do this it's been many
many graduate thesis
many graduate students
started this endeavor and and just
couldn't um really make
some definitely some advances but
not to the degree that satisfied using
any um
application so
uh so that's also an interesting angle
here that we are trying to uh
in a way revert this enzyme to what it
was before so why not
access the version that already existed
when there was no oxygen and see what it
does and what's its specificity towards
co2 was
so yeah i mean this is this is extremely
cool so i'm going to try to say exactly
what you just said to see that it's in
my brain so we can't directly say what
the ancient protein looked like the
ancient enzyme protein but but clearly
it's playing an important role today and
like you say it's kind of clunky and
inefficient so
maybe that's a sign that it's old and
was was very very important back in the
day what you can do using the
phylogenetic trees that we already
talked about is figure out what the dna
used to look like and in principle you
should be able to go from the dna to
assemble the protein and that's that's
the kind of thing you do in your lab
yeah exactly so we infer this is all
statistics and mathematics and
evolutionary models at that point all
computational we then um send the
sequence to a company
they synthesize this to us uh they
charge us some 10 cents per nuclear acid
and then
and then
how long is the sequence
it depends so sometimes it's 1500 um
base pair so but when i first started
they used to charge us a dollar uh per
day so now it's just that now it's ten
cents so it's pretty yeah amazing um and
then uh we they send us back to us
sometimes they can't make it sometimes
they say your sequence is um you know
your secret sucks
and then and then we have to either
choose another target or understand what
so of course i as a you know protein
scientist i love those moments when
something doesn't work that's why it's
exciting okay why is it so bad wow like
so horrible
that it can't even be synthesized that's
very interesting and then um but for the
sake of the project we usually pick a
variant that can be made
and then we um
make these
proteins in the lab we express them
most of the time things don't work as
planned
right because we have to find the
optimal condition for these genes that
uh
you know are not supposed to be here
yeah
but it's also important to notice and i
can think about the fact that past is
not necessarily less optimal i think
when we think about ancient life or
things in the past we tend to think that
somehow today is better and and it's a
very you know human-centric view even i
think that we impose on biology as well
the past conditions weren't necessarily
bad solutions they were optimal and they
were innovative at their time
um and and they need to be treated and
such uh so we are not looking at a less
optimal system you're looking at a
system that was optimal and it's
something else yeah
so so you
and your graduate students invent
basically a code use your science to
figure out what the dna sequence was you
send it off to a company that will
literally make strands of dna and
presumably sometimes it doesn't work
just because
that was not a physical i don't know is
it is it
not possible to strand together
arbitrary collections of a c g t
i do some hold together and some not
sometimes i think they are either super
coil so they they cannot be linearized
in some case some cases they are not
soluble
so so they fail
we need to add uh sometimes rationally
add some sequences to make them more
stable for the downstream application
and in some cases we just you know
say
didn't work it didn't work out this is
very part ways
and i learned
it's important to let go because
sometimes you can get obsessed with them
and say no you it's gonna work out and
no i i now i reached a certain wisdom
very good i
learned to let go of the proteins that
just are not
you know it's difficult to synthesize
them for whatever reason most of the
time they work
and then and then of course it's another
challenge to bring them
back to the lab and purify them and
synthesize them ourselves and we either
engineer them inside the microbe and let
the microbe
create it for us in some cases we do
more um in silicon
applications so
we don't we just do
classic biochemistry experiments it
depends uh
also what what we are trying to
understand we did this with rubisco we
did this with nitrogen fixation enzymes
uh nitrogenases we did this with
translation proteins so
i'm really excited i really think that
there is a lot of
potential here
combining
evolutionary mathematics
models and experiments in synthetic
biology and then applying all these
things to understand paleobiology early
life
it's just so profound we are missing you
know this is lynne margulis saying that
earth the story of life on earth is so
magnificent that you cannot
miss the beginning you need to
understand
the early steps of this um it's just so
mysterious and um exciting so you get in
the mail from amazon uh some dna strands
and what you want i look like you liked
that part i like that part i just like i
just you know you're waiting by the
mailbox for your dna
this is your rebate a lot and sometimes
but you want not the dna the dna is
great but you want the protein and so i
guess you partially answered this but i
was going to ask
do we human beings have the technology
to take a dna strand and make protein
from it or do you have to put it inside
a cell and let biology do the work we
can do this
we have technology to do this without a
cell we can do these cell free
translation expressions uh
expressions relying on self retransition
systems and make them
if they are
easy
we tend to pick
hard problems and we don't realize how
difficult they are until we hit the wall
right and uh so
rubisco is a not an easy enzyme to just
dance around with you need to sort of
every different enzyme or even protein
that you study you need to speak their
language and you need to let it let them
show you what they are and what they
prefer um without inferring or imposing
your own agenda on on them that's a very
i think beauty of studying biology in
general because you're dealing with
living systems
um and and
so every experiment is a different
endeavor in its own right
which can be hard
and one of course one challenge is i i
teach a history of life course
and
students are always shocked at the level
of
unknowns we deal with they're almost
disappointed uh that
you don't know anything
because they want us to i think they
assume that we figured this all out
as you said oh dna and then comes rna
and then comes protein and bam's
translation and then selk shows up and
then before you know it's dinosaurs like
they may be assuming that it's not
and um and it's yeah so they they get
disappointed i think when they hear
that we hardly know anything well and i
like the point you made that you know
we've all seen science fiction movies of
the frozen neanderthal who awakes in the
present day and cannot adapt to current
conditions and in some sense your
proteins are like that right i mean
you're saying you're putting dna
sequences in microbes but they're modern
microbes in modern conditions and even
if they worked well back in the day two
billion years ago right now maybe it's
not so obvious that they will succeed
yeah yes and your careful listeners
already
were i think asking these things to
themselves wait a second she's putting
these things in modern systems so
everything else is modern
you know there's only one thing that's
ancestral and that's that's
exactly right
so we are not able to we're not there
yet and not my group anyway we are not
the ones trying to generate an entire
ancestral organism um that we are
our we are just simply in a very modest
way trying to resurrect a 3 billion year
old life it's very beautiful
but not the entire organism
so we want to fill in the gaps early on
in our conversation we talked about how
maybe we have a handful of evidence of
life in the past so we have a lot of
gaps in between and and the gaps um
between data sets and evidences get more
they become narrower as we reach towards
the present right especially after the
rise of oxygen once the eukaryote shows
up and then we see plants and it's
it's uh the rest is easier and easier we
have more and more evidence for life and
maybe more diverse too um but but such
perhaps using the synthetic systems may
enable us to fill in that gap um in
however artificial it is we need to just
again
make our assumptions and then learn to
live with them and be very honest with
our shortcomings and what we are
capturing and that what we are missing
um and hope that as technology and this
mindset really settles in we are able to
fill in this gap uh ever more and just
to close the book on the rubisco here
you you seem to say that you've been
successful so far at pushing back more
than a billion years so you know there's
some applause that are that is required
there but still not yet all the way back
to the oxygenation event and that's the
goal
that's the goal we are working on it uh
we are also as you know moving
uh our lab so it's uh
we we looked at
we froze everything we put them in the
freezers and just sort of looking at how
significant it is that that that we
might be
storing a tiny piece of earth's history
in our freezers
that's important well so let me just
give you the opportunity to say i i
really enjoyed the rubisco story that i
read about on your website but what
other kinds of things are you trying to
learn from these techniques i mean are
there other
proteins you're trying to make other
events you're focusing in on
yeah so another question we are
interested in aside from
sort of what the rise of oxygen embedded
on proteins like rubisco uh is
understanding how proteins responded uh
elemental changes
in ancient oceans and and how we can use
um enzymes to uh sense the paleo
environments so um that's the that's a
bit more focused on uh
nitrogen fixation
um and
molybdenum amounts and the different
iron levels and how they may have
impacted enzyme change
um so for for
i think this is sort of a concept when
when you think about it almost it's no
brainer that we can use enzymes as a
proxy to understand early earth
but again it's a concept that doesn't
yet really exists
so that's that's really where we are
going with this yeah you mentioned
molybdenum earlier and biologists love
molybdenum and apparently it's very very
necessary so maybe this is a slight
tangent but should we be surprised that
as bizarre an element as molybdenum
is that important to life is it that
life is
opportunistic and noticed that there was
some molybdenum around that was really
useful or is this another aspect in
which
we're really lucky that molybdenum
exists because otherwise life would not
be possible
so this is a very good point and you're
almost quoting my first sentence in the
new proposal that was funded by nasa
and we called it what does life want
right so we don't know
um how life ended up um selecting these
certain elements
is it because they were as you said
available in the environment and there
was abundant amount of these elements
around
and and that's hence um
life picked them because of convenience
versus but or whether there were
different evolutionary
forces in charge that may have not been
directed by the environmental abundance
that we have yet to explore so um i
always say this that we need to uh not
judge biology by the cover right and
it's similar thing when we look at the
environment it's easy to say that there
was a lot of molybdenum therefore
the we see molybdenum in early life but
that's not true actually molybdenum
wasn't high and yet we see the these
enzymes that
that we desperately need to fix the
nitrogen in the atmosphere
need
these metals so how did this happen and
that's one of our latest findings that
we
reconstructed the molybdenum depending
enzyme
nitrogenase and we
think we
traced all the way back to its origins
which is about 2.5 billion year it's not
quite clear
when did this enzyme emerge
um but we find that the enzyme actually
preferred molybdenum early on as well
even though
geologists tell us that early life early
oceans did not have high burden tie in
the molybdenum amounts so that already
tells you that it's not as simple just
so story that
this was in the environment therefore
life picked it but we tend to
go there
and again maybe we need it to start from
somewhere but the story is very
complicated when evolution gets involved
yeah no it's the story is very
complicated which which
uh reminds me of another thing i wanted
to emphasize again has been implicit in
a lot that you've already said that
what you're doing is much more rich and
context dependent than just tracing dna
through time like you keep mentioning
these
physical and geological events that
played a big role right and so to do
what you do you need to constantly be
going back and forth between
phylogenetic trees and and fossils and
all these things and all these stories
need to be told together right
exactly i mean so this is why uh our new
center and we named it uh
muse it's metal utilization and
selection across eons um it is going to
be bringing together uh by a handful of
biologists but mostly geologists and
environmental microbiologists and
physicists and astronomers because uh
clearly and and if if a geologist who
was listening to me maybe thinking oh my
gosh you missed a complete picture in
geology and it's true i did and you know
it's so this is a very um
complicated
intertwined problem understanding you're
trying to understand an entire planet
that existed billions of years ago so it
does require all hands on deck and all
kinds of expertise that will
correct
when maybe a poor little biologist makes
all these assumptions or or a chemist
misses the entire picture of
the power of natural selection
um so
it's funny because tomorrow actually
we're having our first uh meeting as a
group and we will have about 20
uh professors from all of these fields
only talking about medals and and how
they see
um what they see and and we specifically
ask them to keep it very top level so
that we all communicate with each other
you know
especially for non-scientists and i was
like this before i became a scientist
that i thought there's a sort of
universal science language i guess there
is sadly
nothing
but but other than that it's extremely
divided and for problems like this the
challenge is to
break down those walls um
and and and enable communication across
these different disciplines it is harder
than you think
no oh no it's not harder than i think it
might be harder than one thing's but i
i've also tried and it's very very hard
um which reminds me of an example of
this because you use the word metals
and i i bet that for a lot of people
they think of like a chunk of metal
right like a chunk of iron or a wire or
something like that so what's so special
about metals that we should devote a new
center to their use in in biological
history
well you know they are supply theirs
they supply almost all the
um metabolic functions they are the
intermediaries that enable
almost all life components to do their
job right they they do all kinds of cool
chemistry they convert um
reactives to some other product so they
enable all these catalysis
and um so if you remove them from the
picture
most
functions just they will collapse right
so so it is this is why life is a
chemical system and elements are the
building blocks of this
and we also think that
um
understanding the elemental composition
of a planet
uh is so important that it may even tell
us clues about uh the habitability of
that planet so uh we know life relies on
about 30 different elements here and and
and common is shared uh we know
these six of them this uh schnapps
cocktail that astrobiologists like to
call carbon hydrogen nitrogen oxygen
sulfur phosphorus so this cocktail is
important for life it's we see it in is
an essential and then there's all these
ancillary elements
but we don't yet know um how important
it was that life distilled uh out of all
the available metals and elements um
this um this selection whether it was
essential and necessary uh or it's it's
just um
chemically made sense which
may make it more universal we don't know
so
um so that's a that's an interesting
problem and also why uh
we will see more and more
characterization of different planets at
their metal and elemental level
so i'm thinking like a cosmologist now
or even a multiverse cosmologist um
you know if we lived in a universe where
the laws of physics allowed for a
periodic table with 20 or 30 elements
um you could certainly make
most
by mass you know most uh organic
compounds right carbon carbon and
hydrogen with little bits of oxygen and
nitrogen etc in there sulfur but what
you're saying is that
real life here on earth is has also all
these heavier things iron and molybdenum
and potassium or whatever potassium's
not so heavy but you know what i mean
and uh it really seems to rely on them
like maybe it couldn't have worked in
any interesting way if it weren't for
all of those different abilities to
choose a a different atom here or
different atom there to make some fun
kind of enzyme yeah it's all about
life's battery right and and how you
push energy from one
level to the other yeah and how you need
that um difference
between
two different states of maybe two
elements or whatever molecular system
that you're looking
um and uh and that's the battery is is
everything right so and how you feed
that is when it comes to uh this it all
comes down to coordination chemistry and
and physical chemistry and and even when
you look at enzymes like rubisco uh or
photoenzymes or in all all kinds of
other early uh systems that
[Music]
mike russell's favorite um
you know or do you replicate the
methanogens whatever the enzyme is
important for a certain chemistry or
sulfur chemistry it always comes down to
physical coordination phys physical
chemistry and physics it's really true
um
because
life prefers lighter isotopes because of
biophysics like so it is definitely
um
really cool if you
drill it down and there are some people
who look at the quantum states of this
the quantum chemistry of early life and
try to understand uh whether this sort
of chemical coordination had anything to
do
uh
what sort of physical constraints were
acting on what enzymes speak so that's
definitely a big field right now but
some people are trying to apply that to
early life as well and we welcome them
no no yeah everyone everyone is welcome
uh
i mean does learning
does what we've learned from your sort
of paleo genomics um help us think about
life on other planets in our one
universe about both whether it exists
and how to look for it
so we we want to be ready when enough
data arrives to our in our to our hands
so
i wouldn't say that we are there yet in
terms of connecting
ancient planets to
different planets out there
so we can start with our solar system
definitely learning about say mars will
enable us to understand our own planets
ancient past for sure um right because
mars is not as rich in term
our planet definitely has a richer
chemistry than mars that is not to say
that um
martian conditions won't allow us to
understand our early history
so we have a nice control system in our
neighborhood
but when it comes to exoplanets we will
be able to
understand the chemical composition of
these planets especially the atmospheric
composition over the next decade the
technology is going towards there
so even though there is not going to be
a smoking gun of that okay give me
nitrogen and give me molybdenum and
and i think you will have
this the chance of this planet harboring
life or the habitability chances are 40
we are not there yet we don't have an
equation like that yeah um but
uh
every uh decade and we will get there i
think for every the head of research
will each decade will get us there and
um and we want to be ready right because
we tend to treat we think okay there's
nicole's one problem there's one life
there's one sample this is a problem but
that's actually not quite true our past
is itself an alien planet as you also
you know you know asked me right the
early planet we are looking at a place
with this is completely different than
us it's not i look at outside the window
now i see oh i'm in desert so it's a you
know i see quite actually maybe similar
to but there's there's no trees you're
not looking at
mountains you know you're not looking at
this um
the landscape is completely different
than what you see
atmosphere is different the um chemical
composition is different so who is to
say that that is n equals one
yet we miss a big opportunity if we
don't truly understand uh this extra
sample that our planets process through
once in the past
so uh to wind things up i have to ask
you a philosophy question
and it's not entirely my fault it's your
fault because you wrote a provocative
article in eon about exactly this
philosophy question um
of course we're looking for life
elsewhere
and whether or not we find it we'll
probably go there ourselves but you made
an interesting suggestion that we could
just seed the possibility of life
elsewhere on other planets forget about
sending actual living things or or even
people we could like
send the chemistry to other planets and
let life evolve there and
if we could do that should we do it i
guess is the question
yeah so this is a a thought experiment i
i just i boldly went there so
it's it's it is very likely that we will
have a particular solution to life's
origins in our hand
uh i think uh just it may be a general
solution that could lead to a general
solution to understanding or rather
assessing
how far along
any planet that we
are looking at is to reaching that
threshold of chemistry transitioning
into biology
so this may mean that we may reach a
general solution that will allow us to
connect the dots between non-living and
living
anywhere in the universe
right so we are talking about perhaps
knowing what a planet that we are
studying is missing in order to make
that transition
i think this is not to say that we
should do it but but i wanted to uh pose
that we will have this
ability perhaps once we understand life
storage because this is what it will
mean and this is not about spreading our
life
out there this is not about colonizing
different planets this is actually
empowering them and giving them that
maybe nudge um that that they might be
missing themselves uh towards that
threshold and maybe a nudge that will uh
turn into reality over
millions of years of time
uh and and should we do it was the
question uh just because we can and and
that's that's really the the um
the i guess cracks of that article
um
yeah and what is the answer
i i so i think here is an important
thing what we have is very special and
um and this is uh beyond our presence
here that there is a very interesting
chemistry
that there's a very interesting
chemistry that's going on on this planet
that so far we know did not happen
anywhere
and and it may be
important to think that we may want to
protect this chemistry and save it
and this is again not to say that we
should go plant a tree on mars or build
a skyscraper i'm talking about something
more bigger than that actually it's more
about backing up life's chemistry
um and um and uh
yeah i think i think it's just again the
the capability of
unlocking life under a broader area of
circumstances and that's the knowledge
that uh we're getting to i know i'm
dancing around your questions no i think
actually you're you're secretly
convincing me the answer is yes i think
we should do it uh you know if you came
across the planet where you really
didn't have any you were very very very
sure that there wasn't already life
there
right yes we need to be very sure that
there's no right
and we need to understand them well
right so instead of imposing our own
life over there this is more about and
it's maybe an important thought exercise
given that what we did
to uh you know in a way on this planet
to different cultures without completely
understanding them so this is really
appreciating
what we are studying and understanding
it without before even thinking about
meddling and and this is
again not about seeding these planets
with earth's life this is not
terraforming it is not panspermia i
called it protospermia um that again so
it's this sort of empowering the
capacity of these planets to express
their own
um unique forms of life that are not
genetically related to or look nothing
like us
and um and and so it's almost like a
kickstart project uh for you know
thousands or millions of years into the
um
future that is spreading a biotic
potential not the actual architecture
and i think when we talk about we got to
say what we have
such exercise may allow us to think
about how unique it is
what we have here i think perhaps
understanding origin of life or studying
that alone gives you that humility as
well it's overwhelming
what we are not able to do
and overwhelming to see how what
life achieved
and and continue to do so here if we
don't destroy it ourselves as hagen said
that you know
and when maybe studying these problems
and really
thinking about these exercises may give
us that sense of protecting what we have
a little better
no that's very important but
in a much more um
frivolous vein it does not
it's not possible to then resist
wondering whether this happened to us
whether life on earth was you know poked
along by uh in a prometheus kind of way
that's true and that's also you may
remember the episode from star trek of
course but but it's also yeah you may
want to ask yourself we are live and
that does live we are a chemical system
capable of formulating and maybe
sometimes answering questions about its
own existence right or itself do we have
a responsibility or should we have a
prohibition against spreading more of
this yeah
and this is this is important to ask
ourselves and um and
of course is there an ethical difference
between spreading a particular form of
life or spreading um a capacity
and and where is that difference i'm not
the person to answer these things i
don't study space ethics
uh but um but
i think it's a useful exercise
you can ask them yeah and and uh sorry
i'm just you know my imagination is
running now i mean forgetting about
starting life
maybe
uh ancient astronauts as it were came
along and said you know life on this
planet is going but it's kind of stuck
it needs a little help so let's
oxygenate the atmosphere because
otherwise it'll it'll never really be
able to do good metabolism
well that would certainly make an
interesting x-files episode
and with that i think that we've reached
uh about as far as we could take this so
uh bachelor kachar thanks so much for
being on the winescape podcast this is
wonderful
thank you so much for having me
[Music]
you